What I want to do in
this video is step
through the
insertion_sort function
that we wrote in the last video.
But before I do
that, I actually want
to just focus on one part of it,
because I realize that I used
something that you
probably don't recognize,
because we haven't
used it before.
I used the keyword
right over here.
I used break.
And you might guess
what break means,
but now I'll explain
it explicitly.
What break means is break
out of the smallest loop
that you were doing.
So we were taking
our item, and we
kept comparing it to the
thing to the left of it.
Or we were taking value
and comparing things
to the left of it.
And as soon as we found value
not being less than the thing
to the left of it, we
said, hey, we're done.
We don't have to keep
going to the left.
And in that situation, I
want to break the loop.
So we're breaking
this while loop.
And then we just continue in our
next iteration of this for loop
over here.
So that's what break did.
Now with that out of
the way, let's actually
step through this program
on a simple example.
So let's say that someone
calls-- well, let's just
define a to be equal to-- let me
think of a fairly simple list--
2, 1, 2, 1, I don't know, 2,
1, 3-- 2, 1, 3, 2, I think,
is a good list over there.
And let's assume that we are
calling insertion_sort on a.
Let's think about
what's going to happen.
Well, the first thing, of
course, that list-- let's
keep track of all of
the variables here.
So list is, right
from the get-go,
going to refer to 2, 1, 3, 2.
That's list right
from the get-go.
And then we enter into the
function, for index in range.
And let's parse this
part right over here.
So what is len of the list?
So len of our list is the same
thing as len of 2, 1, 3, 2.
And this is just really
the number of elements.
Len is short for length--
not that much shorter.
But len of this is just
going to be 1, 2, 3, 4.
It's going to be equal
to four elements.
So this right over
here is going to be 4.
And then the call, range
between 1 and len of list is 4.
This will return the
list starting at 1,
up to, but not
including 4, 1, 2, 3.
And so these are the
indices we want to use,
because the first index
is this right over here.
Second index is this
right over here.
And the third index
is that over here.
Remember, this is
the 0-th index.
So index is going to keep
incrementing between these two.
It's going to be 1
first, then 3, then 2.
So let me just create
our variable index
whose scope is inside
of the for loop.
So let's say we have index.
Index is going to
start off being
the first item in
this list right here,
the list generated by
range, 1 comma len of list.
So index is going to
start off being 1.
And then over here,
we say value is
equal to the index
element in list.
So let me define
our variable value.
So what is list of 1?
So what is the first
element in the list?
It's the 0-th element.
This is the first element.
So we're looking at
this right over here.
It is the first element,
so that's fair enough.
And then we define i
to be index minus 1.
So let me put i over here.
Do a new color.
So now let's do i.
It is index minus 1.
Index is 1, so
index minus 1 is 0.
So it's the index of the
item to the left of value.
So that is going to be 0.
This index is 1, this is 0.
And then we're saying, while i
is greater than or equal to 0,
do all of this
business over here.
And the first thing
that we do over here
is we compare value
to the object that
is at the i-th
element in the list.
So let me write that over here.
So list at i.
So that is going to be the
0-th element in the list,
so that is 2.
So we're comparing value.
We're comparing 1.
We're saying if 1 is less
than the i-th element in list,
if 1 is less than
2, then do this.
Well, 1 is definitely
less than 2.
We're essentially taking
1 and comparing it
to the thing to the
left and saying, hey,
it's less than that.
So it's less than that.
So let's shift this
2 to the right,
and let's shift 1 to the left.
And so we go into here
and we say, list i plus 1.
So what's i plus
1? i plus 1 is 1.
So this is list of 1, so
this slot right over here.
So this, in yellow
that I just underlined,
that's this slot right
over here. i is 0.
i plus 1 is 1.
So the first item,
or the first slot,
is this slot right over here.
Let's replace it with
whatever is at list
and whatever is in
the i-th element,
or whatever is in the 0 slot,
I guess I should call it.
So let's replace it with this 2.
Right?
Let me make it clear.
And this time around,
this is 2, and this
is the slot where the 1 was.
So we're going to
put this-- we're
going to replace that with 2.
And then in the place
where the 2 was,
we're going to
replace it with value.
And remember,
value was set to 1.
So value is set to 1.
And so our list now
looks like 1, 2, 3, 2.
And hopefully, this
looks familiar,
if you remember when
we first described
the insertion_sort algorithm.
So we go through there.
And now we want to decrement i.
We say whatever i was--
it's 1-- we subtract 1.
So now it's 0.
So the new value for i is 0.
Actually, no, no.
Sorry.
Whatever i was.
i was 0.
You subtract 1 from
that, and now i
is going to be negative 1.
And then we go to
the while loop.
It says while i is greater
than or equal to 0.
Well, i is now negative 1,
so the while loop no longer
applies.
This will return false. i is
not greater than or equal to 0,
so it won't perform
any of this anymore.
And so we'll now go to the
next iteration of the for loop.
And essentially, what
that's signifying
is that we were done
with that element.
We compared all the way to
everything to the left of it,
and it found its
place, or it just
found its place in general.
Now let's go to the next
iteration of the for loop.
Now index is going to
be the next element.
Now index, instead
of being 1, is
going to be the next element
in the list generated
by this expression here.
So index is now going to be 2.
And now list value is what's
ever at the second index.
So it's this item
right over here.
Notice, we were at the
second to the left.
Now we're at the-- or we were
at the first to the left,
or one right to the left of it.
Now we're one space
more to the right.
So value now is going to be 3.
i is going to be index minus 1.
Index is 2.
2 minus 1 is 1.
So this is now 1.
And we say, while i is
greater than or equal to 0.
Well, it's clearly greater
than or equal to 0 now.
So if value is less than
list, the i-th element
in list, so the value is 3.
And is that less than--
well, what's at list i
is no longer 2-- so what's
in the first element?
Well, actually, it is still a 2.
So if we look at the
first element-- list
the i-th element in
list, i is 1, 0, 1.
It is still 2, so I actually
didn't have to cross that out.
It is still going to
be 2 right over there.
And so if 3 is less
than 2, do this.
Well, 3 isn't less
than 2, so you're
going to do the else clause.
And you're just going to
break out of this while loop.
And that made sense,
because you said, look,
we compared 3 immediately
to the thing right
before it, to the left of it.
And we said, hey, 3
is in the right place.
3 is greater than 2.
It's not less than
2, so I'm not going
to do all the shifting business.
I don't have to shift 2 to
the right and 3 to the left
and then look at the next item.
I know that everything to the
left of 3 is already sorted.
So if 3 is not less than
2, it's definitely not
going to be less than
anything to the left of it.
And so we're done.
We leave it the way it is.
And so then we break out.
And then we go to the next
iteration of the for loop.
So now index is going to
be the next item here.
It is now going
to be equal to 3,
the next item in this list
generated by this expression.
So it's now going to be 3.
Index is now going to be 3.
Value is now going
to be 0, 1, 2, 3.
Value is now going to be
this item right over here.
That is going to be value,
because our index is now 3.
So our value is now 2.
Let me cross these guys out.
Let me save some space.
Value is now 2.
And now i is 2.
i is index minus
1, so 3 minus 1.
So that is 2.
So i is now going to be 2.
And the object that is at the
second element of the list, 0,
1, 2 is now going to be 3.
And so the first
thing we do while i
is greater than or
equal to 0-- well,
i is clearly greater
than or equal to 0.
It's 2 right now.
If value-- if 2 is
less than what's
in the i-th slot of list,
so 2 is less than 3,
so we do perform
this right over here.
And so what we do is, whatever
is at list of i plus 1.
I is 2. i plus 1 is 3.
So whatever is at
this slot, which
is the third slot where the 2
was, replace it with whatever
is to the left of it.
So replace it with the 3.
So we're going to
replace this with the 3.
And in the next
element, take whatever
was that slot to the left
where i is, and replace it
with value.
So then we replaced
it with value.
So this thing is now
going to be a 2 again.
And now we decrement i again.
So now i is equal to 1.
And we go through
the while loop again.
I is clearly greater
than or equal to 0.
It is 1.
Value is still 2.
Remember 2, is what
we're comparing
while we go through
this while loop,
but we're comparing to each
of the items to the left.
If 2 is less than whatever is
at the i-th slot in the list.
So the first slot
in the list is a 2.
Well, 2 is equal to that,
but it's not less than that,
so we don't have to
do anything more.
The thing is sorted.
2 is in the right place.
If it's equal to the
thing to the left of it,
we don't have to shift anything.
And that means it's at
least equal or greater
than everything to
the left of that,
since everything
is sorted already.
So then we're done.
Since 2 is not less
than 2, we break out.
And we break out
in the for loop.
It says, OK, let
me see if there's
anything left in this
list to apply index to.
There isn't.
We've used everything
in that list.
And so we break out
of the for loop.
And we're done.
And the list should be sorted.
And we see right here,
the list is sorted.
Our final sorted list
is 1, 2, 2, and 3.